[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANMOL BHAGCHAND: Hi, everyone.
So firstly, welcome
to our guests.
Thanks for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
So our goal I think with this
talk is to kind of, firstly,
celebrate Pride because
it is Pride month.
And then secondly,
kind of challenge some
of the assumptions around what
an LGBTQ person looks like.
So there's lots of diversity
within the LGBTQ community,
not just in terms of
gender orientation,
sexual orientation, but also
in terms of race, of culture.
And this sort of
concentration, we're
concentrating on
differences of religion.
So because these are
kind of sensitive topics,
I just want to sort of
make a couple of points
before we begin.
We tried really hard
to vet these questions
with the panelists and
within our internal team
as well to make sure
they're challenging and
thought-provoking but
still respectful and kind
of inclusive.
And so we'd ask, when we get
to the question and answer
portion with the audience,
that the audience can sort of
try to strike the same balance.
So that's a request to you guys.
And then in the spirit of that
inclusiveness that I was just
talking about, please
note that whenever
we refer to the acronym
LGBTQ, which we'll
be doing quite a lot I guess
during this discussion,
it's sort of just
shorthand for LGBTQQIAAP.
So we definitely want to
include everyone again.
But we're going to be using
that acronym a lot, just
for shorthand purposes.
So those are just a couple of
points before we get started.
I'll just introduce with
a short blurb written
by the panelists themselves
each of the panelists
in their own words.
So I'll start with Kelsey,
who's right to my right here.
So Kelsey is a Long Island
native currently living
and learning and Philadelphia.
She's just completed
her second year of study
at the Lutheran
Theological Seminary
and will be moving to
Santa Monica, California,
in August for a
year-long internship.
She describes herself as
unapologetically queer, black,
and Lutheran.
Her motto is reliance
on sass and grace.
It's a great motto.
She's passionate
about slam poetry,
has a voice for
social justice, and is
an avid seeker of the truth.
So welcome.
KELSEY BROWN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ANMOL BHAGCHAND: And next
we have Sensei Joshin.
So Sensei Joshin is a
co-founder of Village Zendo,
a Zen Buddhist meditation
center in downtown Manhattan.
She began her formal
Zen training in 1986,
spending three years in
residential monastic training.
She now lives with her life
partner, Roshi Enkyo O'Hara.
Besides teaching meditation
and giving Dharma talks,
Sensei Joshin is
a psychotherapist
and is interested in the
interface between spirituality
and psychotherapy.
So welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
And next we have
Rabbi Nancy Wiener.
So Rabbi Nancy Wiener
is the clinical director
of the Center of Pastoral
Counseling at Hebrew Union
College Jewish
Institute of Religion,
where she's an adjunct full
professor of pastoral care
and counseling.
She holds a doctor of ministry
in pastoral counseling,
a master's degree
in Jewish history,
and a master of Hebrew letters.
She sat on the
Central Conference
of American Rabbis' ad hoc
committee on human sexuality
that wrote the official
statements and resolutions
related to rabbinic officiation
at same-sex weddings
and the inclusion of bisexual
and trans-identified Jews.
Her publications include
two books related
to marriage and engagement,
"Beyond the Breaking
Glass: A Spiritual Guide
to your Jewish Wedding"
and "Meeting at the
Well: A Jewish Spiritual
Guide to being Engaged,"
the first inclusive books
published by Jews and for Jews
to address relationship issues
of concern to both
the LGBTQ community
and non-LGBTQ communities.
Her most recent book, "Maps
and Meaning: Levitical Models
of Contemporary
Care" re-examines
issues related to marginalized
individuals and communities
and their enduring relationships
to holiness and community.
So welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
And then lastly, we
have Faisal Alam.
He's a queer-identified Muslim
activist, speaker, and writer
of Pakistani descent.
At age 19, Faisal founded
the Al-Fatiha organization,
which is an
organization dedicated
to supporting and
empowering LGBTIQ Muslims,
and served as its volunteer
director until 2003.
In 2013, Faisal
helped launch Muslims
for Sexual and Gender Diversity,
which is an organization aimed
to connect LGBTQ Muslims,
increase diversity
within the Muslim
community, and promote
a progressive understanding of
Islam that's centered around
inclusion, justice,
and equality.
In 2011, Faisal wasn't invited
to attend the White House iftar
with President Barack Obama.
Faisal was also
named an innovator
by "Advocate
Magazine" and selected
as one of the 30 young
visionaries by "Utne Reader."
So welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
So I think I just might start
with a introductory expository
question.
So as I said, our
goal here today
was to kind of highlight
the intersection
of your religious
identities with your gender,
sexual orientation identities.
And so I guess I
just start by having
you guys describe
each in your own words
how you identify with sort
of both of those categories,
and how--
I guess very broadly--
how you see those
two coming together.
So Kelsey, maybe
starting with you.
KELSEY BROWN: Hi, everyone.
So I am a member of the
Evangelical Lutheran
Church in America, and
I identify as a lesbian.
Where I see those two
intersecting most frequently is
the ELCA for short has a variety
of social statements that we've
published over the
past couple of years,
most importantly
the 2009 decision
which affirmed LGBTQ identities
for ordained ministry.
So the track that I
am on will hopefully
lead me to a parish and
to be a parish pastor.
ANMOL BHAGCHAND: Can
you speak a little bit
about how you kind of came
to your religious identity
and sort of your
formative years and what
that evolution looked like?
And also I guess from
your gender identity,
how that kind of
evolved as well?
KELSEY BROWN: So a little
less fun of a story.
I was born a Lutheran.
My family has been
Lutheran my entire life,
and I have actually been a
member of the same church
for the past 24 years.
So a little boring.
But in my process
of coming out, I
struggled a bit connecting
church and what I was being
taught to what I was feeling.
It was very difficult to
come from a more conservative
pastor.
Not all Lutheran churches act
and think and talk and teach
the same things.
And to hear what he
was saying and then
hear what my family
was saying, affirming
my different identities, it
proved a little bit difficult,
and I actually removed myself a
little bit from the leadership
roles that I had taken within
the church, such as communion
assisting and teaching Sunday
School and choir and things.
I didn't want to be as
connected as I was in the past.
That has changed now due
to public affirmation
by the national church and
some other church bodies
of my various identities.
But then it was rather
difficult. I was about 14,
and then I really cared
what people thought.
ANMOL BHAGCHAND: Sensei.
BARBARA JOSHIN O'HARA: So
I identify as a lesbian Zen
Buddhist.
But it was quite a
journey to get there
because I was raised an
Irish Catholic in Ireland.
And I guess my sense
of the church--
I mean, my family
was very religious.
So we'd go to mass on Sunday.
And so I remember as early as
maybe five or six sitting there
with my parents and my
sisters and my brothers,
and my twin brother was up on
the altar being an altar boy.
So he got to fetch
the crucible of wine
and the water for the priest.
And that seemed
like a lot more fun,
but I couldn't do that
because I was a girl.
So that didn't stop me from
going home and re-enacting.
I became the priest.
And with the sideboard, my
mother's chalices and trophies,
I would offer the Eucharist,
and my brother was my acolyte.
All told, I think
around 16 I realized
that women had pretty
secondary role in the church.
And there were other issues I
had about the church's dogma.
And basically, I felt that
women didn't get a good deal,
and I started into meditation
and yoga on my own.
I didn't know any gay people
growing up in Ireland.
I thought, in fact, around 16,
17, that I was the only one.
And it took me to travel
in France and Spain
to come upon two
women living together.
And that was
actually an awakening
that this is possible.
I mean, I'd read "The
Well of Loneliness,"
but I'd never
actually known anyone
who was able to profess
their love for same gender.
Even in college, there were no
associations or organizations.
So my encounter with
Buddhism came much later
when I came to this
country and read something
that said life is suffering, and
the way out of this suffering
is through our minds,
watching our minds.
And I loved the idea that
my own spirituality was not
going to be mediated
by a third person,
that it took simply sitting on
a cushion counting my breath
to know my true nature.
So that was it.
And I was hooked and met my
partner at this Zen center,
and she went on to start
sitting in her house.
I went into monastic
residence for three years
and really explored the
tradition very deeply and then
came out and joined her.
And the Village Zendo was born.
And so 30 some years
later, it's still
going strong in Soho, Broadway
between Houston and Prince.
And we have a very
vibrant community
of all kinds of people.
NANCY WIENER: So I, like
Kelsey, was born a reformed Jew
and into a reformed
Jewish family,
was very comfortable within
the liberal Jewish tradition,
and was very active as
a child in synagogue
and through my years in
junior high and high school.
I didn't come out
until I was in my 20s,
and I identify as a lesbian.
I went through many
heterosexual relationships,
always feeling that
there was something
that seemed to be missing.
And I had thought of the
rabbinate as a possibility
when I was younger and
had originally thought
that I needed to listen to my
rabbi who said, no, no, no.
You'll be a religious
school teacher
because when I said that there
weren't women rabbis yet.
I chose to go into the
rabbinate because I
felt that there were many ways
that the things that I loved
and the things that I found
most meaningful in my own life
were things that I could
share with other people.
When I applied to
rabbinical school,
the reform movement was already
accepting gay and lesbian
congregants.
They were not at a point
where they had made
a statement about clergy yet.
And so I entered rabbinical
school in the closet
with my partner who
had been out for years
sort of re-entering
the closet with me.
And we found a
spiritual home together
at Congregation [? Batzim ?]
Hatorah here in New York City.
And through my years
in rabbinical school,
I was very active with a
group of other students
who are also I would say at best
semi-closeted at the seminary.
We had many advocates among our
peers, and some of the faculty
was very supportive.
But technically we
couldn't be out.
And particularly when we
finished with our studies,
we were told that when
we applied for jobs
that we were going to end
our careers if we came out
in the process.
Fortunately, the June
after my ordination in May,
the reform rabbinic community,
the Central Conference
of American Rabbis, voted to
accept gay and lesbian clergy
in their midst.
And so for my entire rabbinate,
that has been a possibility.
FAISAL ALAM: Yeah, as
Kelsey and the rabbi,
I also grew up in
a Muslim household.
I identify as queer Muslim
of Pakistani descent.
And depending on
how far back you
want to go in my
parents history,
you know pre-partition
India, I was born in Germany
and lived in Saudi
Arabia, and then
grew up in a small
town in Connecticut.
So when people are like,
identify your identity or where
are you from?
I'm always like, how far
back do you want to go,
or let's just say
I'm from Connecticut.
So I moved here when I was
10, and my parents enrolled
my brother and I and
our Sunday School
at our mosque, which was nearby.
And that's primarily where I
learned the tenets of my faith,
learned about Islam, et
cetera, and at the same time
was going to a
predominantly white school
in the suburbs of Connecticut.
So I grew up pretty much
with a very dual identity
of being sort of American
when I was in public school
and then being sort of Pakistani
and Muslim on the weekends,
and all the while also coming
to realize that I was gay
and also thinking that
I was the only one.
I don't think I was
raised necessarily
in a homophobic environment,
but at our mosque,
at our Sunday School there were
probably about two weekends
where we spent talking about
homosexuality and Islam.
And the teaching essentially
was that, just like Christianity
and Judaism, Islam also
condemns homosexuality.
You can't be gay and Muslim.
That doesn't exist.
And there's sort of no no
ifs, ands, or buts about it.
And so it was definitely
very challenging sort
of realizing that they
were talking about me,
and so how could I
be gay and Muslim?
Like, why would God you know
instill these feelings inside
of me if he or she-- depending
on how you view God--
was going to condemn you later?
And so my journey really was
to find other LGBT Muslims,
and that's essentially
what I did when I was 19
is to look for
other LGBT Muslims
and really create a
community for myself.
And that was almost
20 years ago.
And unlike Protestant
denominations of Christianity
or sects of Judaism, within
Sunni Islam, which is about 80%
of Muslims, there
isn't a hierarchy.
So there aren't
statements necessarily
that the church or the
rabbinical institution
can issue supporting
LGBT people.
And so in the United
States at least,
depending on where you are,
it depends on which mosque
you're going to
or which community
you're going to in terms of
how open or welcoming they
may be to LGBT people.
ANMOL BHAGCHAND:
Very interesting.
I'd like to get even more
personal actually, if we could,
and actually ask you guys
about the coming out process,
I guess.
So coming out involves maybe
coming out to yourself.
As we know, there's so
many different stages.
There's coming out to yourself,
coming out to your parents,
coming out to
family and friends.
I'm particularly curious
about your coming out process
with whichever higher
power you believe in
and what kind of shape
and form that took
and how you reached a harmonious
relationship with that
if you did.
KELSEY BROWN: So I find
my relationship with God
to be very relational.
I thought it was
really funny, if we
view God as feminine or
masculine, male or female.
God to me is just God,
and I try my hardest
to instill that in the
people that I teach
and the conversations
that I have with others.
So for me, my coming
out experience to God
was just a check in to say, hey,
by the way, you know I'm gay,
but like now I know I'm gay.
So I'm gay.
It was much more
interesting to explore
the idea of coming out
to my faith community
than to God's self.
I did come from a particular
community that preached
homophobia from the pulpit.
And although that may not be the
general consensus of many ELCA
Lutheran congregations,
for me it was.
So I have been a member
there my entire life,
but I'm still not out
to that community.
And for a variety of reasons,
I live fully as myself
there without
having to say a lot.
And they're OK with that.
God, on the other
hand, has affirmed me
through scripture and people
that I have met and interacted
with to sort of give
me the go-ahead.
I find a lot of assurance
in being affirmed
by the seminary
in which I attend,
or the conferences and
congregations in which I
support and preach and teach at.
That when they affirm
my identity fully
and wholeheartedly as
unapologetically black, gay,
and Lutheran, that that is
God affirming that as well.
BARBARA JOSHIN O'HARA:
So I think for me it
was the whole issue
around my sexuality
that forced me into this
kind of inward search
that started me on questioning
everything and sort of seeing
that maybe reality was surfaces,
that there was something
certainly going on with me that
had no representation outside.
And so it was this sense of
having to figure out on my own.
And so that I think is what
actually led me on this search.
I knew I was not going to get
any help from the Catholic
Church with this, nor my
parents, nor my school,
nor my neighborhood,
or my country.
I found myself truly
alone, and this then
started this inward quest--
yoga, meditation, and then
actually traveling, leaving
home.
Which is OK, because in
the Buddhist tradition
that has good antecedents.
The Buddha also left
home on a quest.
And so I do think my
sexuality started me
on my spiritual quest.
NANCY WIENER: I was raised
with three main ideas that
were related to God.
One was that God created a world
that was filled with diversity.
The second was that God was a
god that liberated our people.
And the third was
that the encounter
with God at Mount Sinai made
us responsible for ourselves
and for taking
care of the world.
Those three things
led me to question
how the group that had
raised me and formed me
didn't accept me
fully as a lesbian.
And so the challenge went
to the community as opposed
to a challenge to God.
It was a question
of if you believe
that we are all supposed to be
free people, why am I not free?
If I'm supposed to be
responsible for who I am
and for making the
world a better place,
why aren't we all
doing this together?
And it really became
the impetus for me
to work within my
religious community
to foster and work
towards the changes
that I felt were consistent
with who we claim
to be as a religious group.
FAISAL ALAM: Yeah, these are
very challenging questions,
Anmol.
I was very impressed--
not your traditional
questions that we usually
get, which is like, what
does your religion say?
And so I think my relationship
with my higher power
and God is not
necessarily harmonious
because I do come from a
tradition that is viewed
as inherently homophobic.
And many instances of that
are apparent around the world.
And so what I
struggle with I think
is I don't have a mosque
for example or a community
that I can call my own,
especially as a very out queer
Muslim.
If I wasn't out,
I probably could.
But where I do find
community and I do
find God is when I'm
with other queer Muslims.
And especially when you know we
have conferences and retreats
around the country.
During prayer times, we don't
segregate men and women.
We allow women to lead prayers.
We have folks come as
they are regardless
of what they're wearing.
And that's a really,
really powerful experience
to be with a group of
people without being forced
into these gender rigidities
that a lot of mosques
and in clothing rigidity.
So I think on a personal
level, I'm still struggling.
I've spent a lot
of time in therapy
and probably like thousands
of dollars figuring this out.
But I'm also re-imagining
what my God is.
And so, as Muslims we're taught,
that God Allah is the most
forgiving the most merciful.
And from that I think comes the
element of most loving, most
accepting as well, and
really sort of reframing
my own sort of
understanding of God
and realizing that the
religion, which is actually
just a man-made phenomenon
mostly by straight men who want
to stay in power, that
God does not necessarily
speak through them.
And in the marginalized
voices within our faith
that is where my
God really lies.
ANMOL BHAGCHAND: Cool.
Very interesting.
So I'd like to switch
gears now a little bit
to talk about the human,
social, political, component
behind religion.
I think you've talked about
your own personal experiences
with your spirituality,
your faith.
But I'm particularly curious
how you see your LGBTQ status.
I think you've touched
upon this a little bit.
How you see your
LGBTQ status fitting
in with the larger
religious community
that you're a part of?
And then also,
conversely, how do you
see your religious identity
fitting in harmoniously
or not harmoniously with
the LGBTQ community?
Do you find that
there is some sort
of hesitancy or discrimination
on that side as well?
So I'm curious about both sides.
KELSEY BROWN: So
when I tell people
I'm going to be a pastor,
their first reaction is, wait,
but you're gay.
And not questioning my
call or the way in which
I feel connected to
God and why I feel
called to pursue this
as a career, but more
how I have reconciled my
identity to be in a place
where many deem not safe.
And I have found that through
working with the ELCA LGBT
advocacy group Proclaim that
I have found many people that
are struggling to place these
particular identities not
on a hierarchy, but
rather on a continuum of--
some days when I'm in
the church I am Lutheran,
and that is what I am doing.
And then some days I am
there but I am very queer.
And then the other
days I am there,
and I am battling
white supremacy which
is deeply rooted in the ELCA.
And then I am
unapologetically black.
And some days all three
of those are battling
to see which one will win.
It has been much more
difficult to live
into each of those identities
in our political climate.
And I have watched as
many congregations have
struggled to place church above
some of those other identities.
And perhaps that's our job.
Perhaps that is
what we are called
to do is to place God
above any of those.
But I don't think I can all
the time, and I try not to
because I think that God
has called the marginalized
and called the oppressed
to be the people that
push the message forward.
And if I can't use each
of those identities
to further God's message,
then I'm kind of wasting it.
ANMOL BHAGCHAND: Sensei.
BARBARA JOSHIN O'HARA:
So Zen Buddhism
is a very ancient tradition.
It's over 1,000 years old,
and our particular lineage
comes through the
Chinese, Japanese.
But the beauty of
it right now is
that, in America, we don't have
a lot of institutional baggage.
We don't have to
respond to a Vatican
or a main central agency
that's handing down orders.
And so it keeps
reinventing itself.
It's not that we don't
hold to the traditions,
but we're constantly looking
at ways to make them relevant.
So it seems that we ourselves
and the Village Zendo, we
hold the tradition, but we
make it just a community that
is to practice essentially
meditating and getting to know
what our true nature is.
So we have always
had gay people come.
We're in the village.
We've had a sitting
group a GMHC,
and so we were very active in
the '90s with the AIDS crisis.
We marched as the Zen queers
in the gay pride parade.
So it's very fluid,
it's non-problematic.
And because you have
two lesbians in charge,
word gets round, and
people feel at home.
NANCY WIENER: I sit in a
unique place in the broader
Jewish world, being part
of Reform Judaism, which
is in the liberal
end of the spectrum.
Being a woman rabbi and being
a lesbian are absolutely fine
and welcomed within the
liberal Jewish world.
And I know that when
I march in a gay pride
parade with a
Jewish group, there
are Jews on the sidelines
screaming and yelling
and saying that we
shouldn't exist,
that we're an
abomination, et cetera.
I get equal heat from the most
right-wing Jewish groups as
well for being a woman rabbi.
As far as they're
concerned, women
shouldn't be ordained
as rabbis and should
have a much more proscribed
role within the Jewish world.
My feeling is that Judaism
is a religious group
and an ethnic group that
has evolved over time.
We no more look like the Jews
who are described in the Bible
than any of you look
like your ancestors
from hundreds or
thousands of years ago.
And our strength
is in our ability
to distill the enduring
values and teachings
and find ways to express them
and to enact them in the world
that we're living in today.
It doesn't mean that
it's always an easy place
to be since there are
people who question
our very right to exist.
But it also feels like the
place where I need to be
and where I can make the
most important contributions
to the world and to our society.
FAISAL ALAM: Yeah, I
think the intersection
of being Muslim
and being queer, I
think for a long time our sort
of mainstream LGBT communities,
especially political
organizations,
were afraid to go into or
at least approach religion.
And so it's remarkable that
now a place like Google
is actually having a
conversation on faith,
which just shows the
importance of including
LGBT people of faith.
Because we've always been
part of the struggle.
And that's all to say
that for LGBT Muslims,
and for myself particularly,
we stand especially
in this political climate
on at many intersections.
We're a multiracial group,
multiethnic community,
multigenerational.
I myself am an immigrant.
I'm a person of color.
And so depending
on where I'm going,
I have to wear specific hats.
And I guess what I
will say is oftentimes
when we're within the LGBT
communities, we're saying,
hey, don't forget
about the Muslims.
And not just mainstream
straight Muslims.
Like, hello, there are
queer Muslims here as well.
And then when we're going
into Muslim communities,
we're saying the same
thing with the LGBT voice.
And so right now I think
we are particularly
a wedge issue that
is being used not
only by this administration, but
by conservative voices, where
they're pitting Muslims
against LGBT people.
And we saw this really
after Orlando as well as
in rhetoric that is coming
from the administration now.
So we sort of
stand in the middle
and say that we don't want to
be that wedge issue, that we
do belong to both of
these communities,
and that it's much
more complicated.
Our identities and our politics
are much more complicated
than you all would
like it to be.
ANMOL BHAGCHAND: You brought up
the Pulse nightclub incident.
I think it would be interesting
to explore that a little bit
more.
Can you expand on
anything else that
came out from your
experience of that incident,
specifically in relation
to how the larger Islam
community views gay people
or views the LGBT community?
FAISAL ALAM: Yeah, the
attack in Orlando--
we're coming up on the one-year
anniversary on June 12--
was a real pivotal
point for us I
think as Muslim-Americans
as well as LGBT Muslims.
It was the first time that
national civic leaders,
national civic
Muslim organizations
came out in support
of LGBT rights,
and that was a pretty
remarkable time.
And so where we stand
when that happened was,
let's see what your
commitment really is now.
Like, a, we haven't
forgotten about things
that have been said in the
past, but we want to show up.
I think it's horrible that a
tragedy is what sometimes it
takes for communities to come
together and find common voice.
And so this was
really an opening
that we have taken
advantage of and moved
into by engaging mainstream
Muslim communities
around issues of inclusion
and acceptance of LGBT people.
And at the same time, it
really put our community
in a spotlight that we
were not ready to be in.
And it really brought
out a lot of trauma,
a lot of mental health
challenges that our communities
face because all of a sudden
the media was just like,
we want to talk to like
any queer Muslim that we
can in any kind of capacity.
And so one of the things that
we also were doing at the time
was really controlling the
narrative that was coming out
because the mainstream
narrative would be,
look, here's a Muslim extremist
who could or could not
have been gay, and
maybe you know something
about that we don't know.
And so making this connection
that Islam is homophobic,
and that's why this person
you know chose what to do.
And what we sort of
came in and said was,
yeah, it's not that easy.
Let's talk about
toxic masculinity.
Let's talk about gun
violence in this country.
These are all other
reasons why this attack
could have happened.
ANMOL BHAGCHAND: Thank you.
So I'm going ask one last
question before we open it up
to questions from the audience
and from the live stream.
So we might have a lot of people
watching this over YouTube
eventually, and I
guess I'd just like
to ask you guys
in your own words,
if there's a young person
watching who's just
kind of struggling with
reconciling these identities
and sees them as
adversarial perhaps, what
advice you might give them?
KELSEY BROWN: So I try really
hard not to use scripture
in the ways in which scripture
is used to sort of batter
the LGBT community.
And it sounds really cliche
to say that you are fearfully
and wonderfully made.
But what I find most
affirming is the idea
that before we were born
that God created us.
And that in that creation,
that creation was perfect.
And the way in which God
created the globe and the earth
and said that it was good, that
in our very being we are good.
I think that that is
what I needed to hear
and could have
benefited in hearing
a lot earlier than I did.
But on top of that, we
talked about in the room
before the ability
to occupy space
and to claim our
personhood in this space.
And I would say that,
by sitting here and all
of us being a part
of this discussion,
that you can do this, too.
God and a higher
power, for me, that God
is calling us to a
new thing, to be proud
and to proclaim him even
in the midst of people
trying to shut us up.
BARBARA JOSHIN O'HARA:
Hard to top that.
Beautiful.
Yeah, the same thing.
That we're each a
manifestation of the divine.
I think it does help also to
find support, to find another,
so that one doesn't
have to be alone.
Aloneness has its functions.
But I think in the end,
having other people
so that one can relax
into self-acceptance.
So finding others that you can
identify with and relate to,
I think is key.
NANCY WIENER: I would agree.
I would say to somebody
that it's really important
to know that they're not alone.
That if they look,
they can find people
who are waiting to greet
them and accept them and say
we are a community together.
And that the voices
that are telling them
that they can't be
who they are are
voices that will
continue to exist
but aren't the only voices
that are there to be heard,
and that they should really try
to hear the other voices that
are out there.
FAISAL ALAM: Yeah,
the Koran you know
says that we are
created in God's image.
And if God is perfect,
then we are also
perfect in all of who we are.
And I always say that
it doesn't get better.
It gets easier, but it doesn't
necessarily get better.
And that it's challenging, but
there are many more resources
than there were before.
There are community
groups around the country.
There are many, many
outlets through social media
for people to connect with and
talk to other LGBT Muslims.
And there's also a growing
progressive Muslim community
that is both LGBT and straight
and that welcomes LGBT people.
And there are now
places of worship
in a lot of major cities where
people can go and participate
in religious
services or prayers.
Here in New York,
for example, there's
a queer Muslim
community that holds
an iftar, the breaking of
the fast during Ramadan,
almost every day at
somebody's house.
And these are really
magical, special places
that young people are
welcome to and can access.
NANCY WIENER: If I can,
I'd like to add two things.
One is that we, too, emphasize
the idea that we're all
created in God's image.
We also say there's a
prayer in Judaism that
praises God for the
diversity of creation,
and that that is a key idea.
And we see our
mission in the world
is to make the world
a better place,
and part of that is creating
a more inclusive world
and that they, too, can
be part of that process.
ANMOL BHAGCHAND: Great.
Thank you.
So we have about
10 minutes left.
I just want to open up for
questions in the audience.
I know there's a lot of
people watching on live stream
as well.
So there's a Dory as well.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: So this
question is for you.
Correct me if I'm
wrong, you said
there isn't a mosque
that is LGBT friendly.
And it strikes me as
a lonely place to be.
I mean, you can have the private
prayer meetings and stuff
like that.
And I think in Christianity
there are outlets,
there are churches.
You even find a rogue
Catholic priest every once
in a while that will give
a like a gay-friendly mass,
and in Judaism you have
the progressive side.
Are there LGBT people working
to interpret scripture
at sort of an imam
level to create
a gay-friendly mosque or
a gay-friendly safe zone
for the religion?
Do you know anything about?
And is it worth it, or will that
just create sort of a backlash?
FAISAL ALAM: So there
are definitely mosques
that are LGBT welcoming.
They aren't necessarily
open about it.
I think there is a fear that
there will be a backlash.
So there are imams who
have privately told
us that they are
open and welcoming,
but there isn't anyone who
is ready to take that mantle,
if you will, at least
a religious leader.
There are many academics
and scholars, though--
Muslim scholars and
academics-- that
have come out and
support, especially
when marriage equality was on
the table as a civil rights
issue.
And there aren't necessarily
LGBT-specific mosques,
but there are these progressive
Muslim spiritual spaces
that I was talking about.
Sometimes they're in churches.
Sometimes they're
in people's houses.
And it's really just
only a matter of time
before they become brick
and mortar mosques.
And also, just to
recognize that there
is such an ideological
difference across the country.
And even in a place like New
York, one mosque to another
can be extremely
different when it
comes to any sort of
ideology, especially when it
comes to social issues.
But again, I think it's
only a matter of time,
and it's probably in
the next five years
that I'll see mainstream,
at least some imams
coming out in support
and talking about that we
should at least be welcoming.
Even though we may
disagree theologically,
that Muslims should not
reject LGBT children.
This was something that
Orthodox Judaism and a group
of orthodox Jewish rabbis
on issued a statement
a few years ago, which
was a historic moment
for the orthodox
Jewish community.
And I think we will be
following a similar path.
AUDIENCE: Kind of a follow up.
So the academic
scholars, are there
are people working within
the Quran itself saying,
no, you're reading this wrong.
This means x, this means
y, and reinterpreting
some of the more what are
read as anti-gay passages.
I guess, are they backing it up
with, they're going to come out
like, we have the support.
FAISAL ALAM: Yes, there are.
There's a professor by the
name of Scott Kugle who wrote
"Islam and Homosexuality."
There are also feminist
Muslim scholars now
who have already done work
theologically around issues
of gender equity and
gender equality, who
are now looking at sexuality
as sort of a follow-up of that.
So people like Dr. Amina Wadud,
Kecia Ali, some of these folks
who are on the
forefront around talking
about gender and sexuality
are now looking at LGBT issues
as well.
So there are more articles
and academic things that
are being written about those.
ANMOL BHAGCHAND: Yep.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
This is for anyone.
What's the best thing allies who
may be struggling with religion
as well, who are maybe
on the side of it sucks,
what's the best thing
they can do for you guys?
Because it can be
hard when religion,
there are a lot of
bad parts of it.
I grew up Roman Catholic, so
I have my feelings about that.
So what can I do
or what can allies
do to support the LGBT
community without totally
bashing religion if we may feel
our own type of way about it?
ANMOL BHAGCHAND: Anyone
want to take that one?
KELSEY BROWN: I would say
probably acknowledging
existence is the most--
it sounds kind of silly--
but probably the most
affirming part is for someone
to say, you exist in this space,
and I am affirming that
you are here and I am here.
One of the most beautiful
things that my mom ever
did for me in church is,
when there was this hate
speech being preached from the
pulpit, she would hold my hand
and she would squeeze
it really tight.
She let me know
that she affirmed
that I was able to
be there, and that
was an important place for me.
NANCY WIENER: Also,
naming the relationships
that you're seeing for what they
are as opposed to passing them
off as something else.
Many years ago, I was
at a synagogue speaking
with a women's
group where they had
said that they had
opened their doors,
and they were
welcoming, et cetera.
And they wanted to know how
they could make that known more.
And I was explaining
to them that one
of the things that they
needed to challenge themselves
to think about was how they
could make the space one where,
at the end of services when
people would turn and kiss
the people that they were
with, that it wouldn't
be uncomfortable for people
to see two women or two men
kissing each other at
the end of the service.
Everybody else's
family is doing it.
If the families were really
going to be fully welcomed,
then there should be a space
where that could happen.
It seems sort of
like a no-brainer,
but it's a big deal
for a congregation
to reach a point where that's
OK and to have the background
discussions where
they can say, if we
say we're a diverse group,
then that diversity needs
to be expressed in the ways
that are normative for everyone
in terms of how
we show affection.
And really to encourage
people to express themselves
in more open ways so
that people can then
move beyond feeling that
there is a barrier for them
to express themselves.
ANMOL BHAGCHAND: Thank you.
We have like two minutes left.
Maybe if there's
like one really quick
question we can take one more.
If not?
No?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I know Anmol
asked for a quick question,
so maybe this isn't.
But regardless, sorry.
You gave some
really great advice
to people who are
struggling, but many of you
mentioned moments when you
encountered these roadblocks
or these contradictions.
And I'm curious, how do you
personally overcome those
emotionally or psychologically?
What do you think
or say to yourselves
when that experience occurs
that empowers you to get past it
or transcend it?
Sorry.
It's a long, complex question,
but seemed important.
BARBARA JOSHIN O'HARA:
Well, from the Zen Buddhist
tradition, we
actually use koans,
which are designed to be like
roadblocks to the rational mind
and to frustrate
our usual approach,
and to generate a situation
where you're really
up against it.
And interesting things,
I think, can happen.
There can be a
force to surrender.
to And these are
moments when we do,
at least I've experienced,
when we come in contact
with that which is
larger than just
my own self-encapsulated
identity or sense of control.
That's what comes to
me is that roadblocks
are not to be feared.
They can be a genesis
for awakening.
ANMOL BHAGCHAND: Thank you.
That's a good note
to end on, I think.
So we're sort of out of time.
I have like 20 more questions
that I wanted to ask you guys.
So thank you, first of all.
It was a fascinating discussion.
Thank you for joining.
[APPLAUSE]